quand marion cotillard arrive le disait
histoire d'amour entre son personnage et
celui interprété par adam treiber
bonsoir omar et lyon c'est toujours un
plaisir de vos buzz est toujours aussi
somptueuse merci alors ce film de leos
carax annexes anne est une histoire de
timing parce que je crois qu'au
démarrage détiennent pas disponible
quand ils devaient se tourner et puis
finalement les planètes étaient bien
alignés
oui effectivement il ya ces sont des
films aujourd'hui qui sont difficiles à
à financer parce qu'ils sont définis
particulier mais c'est aussi toute la
diversité de notre cinéma français et
puis c'est carax
et effectivement ils m'avaient
rencontrés il ya cinq ans j'étais pas
disponibles les deux ans plus tard ils
sont venus me chercher avec le nouveau
producteur charles gillibert et et du
coup j'ai eu la joie de pouvoir
participer à ce projet et sa licence
donc d'être là ce soir et connait tous
le défendre et de donner mes livres
j'adore venir au festival de cannes et
dayraut festival de cannes avec un film
aussi grandiose c'est ça procure
beaucoup de joie il peur de le faire
l'ouverture de cannes c'est un petit
stress ou pas du tout
non c'est pas stressant de monter
montrer le film c'est tout ça qui est un
peu intimidant toujours donc j'accepte
que ce soit intimidant et vous allez
qu'il ya beaucoup d'amour en tout cas
pour vous ici à cannes merci beaucoup
marion merci